You might see the value of things
before you see the object itself.
I mean,
there are people,
for example,
who are blind.
They have blindsight,
they can recognize emotions
on faces without knowing,
they can see,
so that's partly because their retinas
are attached to their amygdala.
Your retina is attached
to a lot of your body,
not just your visual cortex.
It's attached to your spinal cord.
It's attached to your nervous system
at multiple levels of analysis
simultaneously,
and so you can use your eyes to detect
things that you don't know you're seeing.
So then what is in some sense,
what you often detect under those
circumstances is valence value.
So you're very good,
for example,
at detecting teeth and predatory eyes and
the reasons for that are self evident.
Fundamentally.